es geht um die korona demonstrationen am
brandenburger tor in der hauptstadt rund
um die friedrichstraße zehntausende
menschen haben sich dort
zusammengefunden um gegen die korona
regeln zu demonstrieren jetzt will die
polizei offenbar die demonstration
auflösen die hygienemaßnahmen konnten
nicht eingehalten werden die masken
pflicht die polizei dann durchsetzen
wollte der wurde wohl nicht gefolgt und
wir wollen jetzt zu den demonstrationen
schalten live in die demonstration
hinein dort steht nämlich meine kollegin
angelique gi sie ist den ganzen tag
bereits vor ort
man schlägt jetzt hören wir die
nachricht dass die demonstration
aufgelöst werden soll was kannst du uns
darüber berichten
ja es gab vorher vor ungefähr zehn
minuten lautsprecherdurchsagen am
brandenburger tor wie sitzen hinter mir
das soll da wurde durch gesagt es muss
sich an die gene maßnahmen gehalten
werden sonst wird diese demonstration
aufgelöst
die masse an menschen bewegt sich jetzt
vom brandenburger tor richtung
siegessäule
das ist wohl der offiziell angemeldete
zu hier wird immer noch keinen abstand
gehalten und hier wird auch keine
hygiene maßnahmen eingehalten es wird
keine maske getragen
das würde ja auch dazu aufgerufen ganz
klar keine masken zu tragen
es werden immer noch die gleichen
theorie die hier erzählt und die masse
bewegt sich jetzt trotzdem weiter
richtung siegessäule
wir sehen könnte es ja eine masse an
menschen wir können einfach mal hinter
mich zeigen wie viele leute denn
unterwegs sind hier auf der straße des
17 juni und es werden auf gar keinen
fall weniger
wer es gab einige festnahmen weil sich
ihr bericht es gab einige festnahmen
weiß ich eben nicht an die bonner
maßnahmen gehalten würden jetzt schon
ein paar leute mitreißen worden das
sehen die gestern versprochen also ganze
heinricht andrea es wird noch nicht als
witz humor oder video unsinn erzählt
warum tragen sie eigentlich keine maske
warum sollte ich denn eingetragen es ist
eine vorschrift rede ich doch mal ganz
kurz umdrehte ich doch warum rede ich
doch mal um
warum sollte ich eine tragen von wem der
herr lauterbach hat vor kurzem etwas zum
besten gegeben okay wir sehen es werden
hier gut ist der theorien verbreitet und
es wird sich nicht an der theorie gene
maßnahmen berichten wenn man offenbar
nicht die meinung der demonstranten bzw
wenn man einen objektiv darüber
berichten möchte uns wird die arbeit
dort enorm erschwert wir werden
versuchen dort die lage erst mal zur
ruhe kommen zu lassen angelique und wir
werden uns später noch mal bei dir
melden vielen herzlichen dank auf jeden
fall für deinen einsatz und seine arbeit
vor ort einfach mal sehen wir werden
jetzt gerade von menschen hier
single wenn wir uns einfach mal und wir
wurden heute bestimmt wir werden uns
wurde gesagt dass wir ihnen zeigen dass
sie nicht erwünscht sind
gewichtheben also mensch nur monsheim
werden um die leute sind sicherlich
attraktiv allein weil wir hier sehen
kannst du mich hören wie reagiert die
polizei vor ort ist hier 3000 beamte im
einsatz jetzt sind die banken dran
wir sehen hier keine polizei
wir sehen hier keine polizei ich weiß es
in 3000 beamte im einsatz und die werden
auch in der nächsten zeit die maßnahmen
durchsetzen
es wird durchgesetzt auf jeden fall
wahrscheinlich es wurde ja vorher schon
am brandenburger tor die durchsage
gemacht dass diese demonstration
aufgelöst wird wenn sich nicht an die
maßnahmen gehalten wird
umzingelt von leuten
wir wurden vorher mit wasser bespritzt
aus einem munde
also es ist wirklich universität kann
man sagen es uns menschen lassen um uns
herum haben sich versammelt
wir schreiben uns an wir wurden mit
wasser bespritzt es wurde uns wie
wohngebieten zu gehen
wir bleiben natürlich und berichten
haben einen mit den menschen die dort
jetzt belagern noch reden
[Musik]
eine möglichkeit hierzu geben es wird
[Applaus]
dagegen stehen
alle arten an asse gelandet
[Musik]
keine haben werde
dann werden
[Musik]
und entscheiden es gibt einfach nur
erschreckend oder das ist im moment kein
durch die romane einen moment zeit eben
dort vielleicht eine andere situation
auszusuchen das ist auch sehr schwer das
zu verstehen ich glaube es ist sehr
schwer
von dort aus zu berichten wenn man es in
den westen wo er umzingelt wird